desastre arqueológico en Chile un enorme
incendio forestal en la isla de Pascua
causó la pérdida de aproximadamente unos
80 moáis las icónicas estatuas de piedra
ubicadas en el parque nacional rapanui
en territorio insular chileno sobre el
océano Pacífico las autoridades
catalogaron el daño de las llamas como
irreparables
aproximadamente en un sector bastante
sensible de La Isla porque Presenta una
riqueza arqueológica que debe ser de las
más importantes tal vez de la Polinesia
también
arrasó mucho de patrimonio natural harto
de plantas nativas que todavía
permanecen en el lugar las llamas que
iniciaron el pasado lunes 3 de octubre
ya lograron ser controladas sin embargo
se desconocen las causas del incendio
pero las autoridades tienen la hipótesis
de que fue producto de malos manejos por
parte de ganaderos la isla de Pascua se
encuentra ubicada a 3.500 kilómetros del
continente americano y es por
aproximadamente 8.000 personas según las
autoridades arqueológicas La Isla
alberga unas 900 estatuas y más de 300
plataformas ceremoniales
realmente fue fue muy triste ver el el
daño causado por el fuego pero
lamentablemente
hubiéramos tenido la cantidad de gente
suficiente no hubiera sido capaz porque
las condiciones no estaban dadas para
trabajar la confederación sucedió tan
solo dos meses después de que la isla
abriera de nuevo al público tras dos
años y medio de cierre total a causa de
la pandemia siendo el turismo en la
principal fuente de acceso económica
para sus habitantes